de qué tipo de terrenos estamos hablando
y qué alternativas tienen los dueños de
estos territorios este decreto para
expropiar estos predios y las
instalaciones que hay adentro de ellos y
es algo que no tiene marcha atrás el
decreto señala que la secretaria de
desarrollo agrario territorial y urbano
comenzará a tomar posesión de estos
terrenos y nada podrá detenerlos los
propietarios de estos terrenos tendrán
diez días hábiles para poder impugnar
pero únicamente la cantidad con la que
van a ser indemnizados por esta
expropiación ya el gobierno hará las
requisiciones a la secretaria de
hacienda para contar con estos montos
para indemnizar a los dueños de estos
predios pero es algo que ya se considera
de utilidad pública y a partir de que
entre en vigor ese decreto es decir a
partir de mañana mismo podrá el gobierno
tomar estos terrenos mario ha habido
mucha controversia como va litigio en
torno a esta obra y qué ha pasado con
los amparos en trámite y qué postura
tiene el gobierno al respecto
así es es muy divertida y justamente
este día el juez de yucatán concedió una
segunda suspensión definitiva contra el
tramo 5 de esta obra del tren maya y con
lo que ya pues no podrían en teoría
continuar los trabajos no obstante el
presidente de lópez obrador ha dicho que
en tanto que ya ha sido considerada de
seguridad nacional nada podrá detener la
obra y él está desestimando las
sentencias judiciales a pesar de que
existe llevan dos suspensiones
definitivas y aún hay otras tres
suspensiones provisionales